>> Greg: THE FAMILY OF
YESTERDAY'S FAILED NEW YORK
BOMBER.
ATTACKING LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
SO-CALLED HEAVY-HANDED TACTICS.
>> WE ARE ALSO OUTRAGED BY THE
BEHAVIOR OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS WHO HAVE HELD CHILDREN
AS SMALL AS 4 YEARS OLD OUT OF
THE COLD AND WHO PULLED A
TEENAGER OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL
CLASSES TO INTERROGATE HIM
WITHOUT A LAWYER, WITHOUT HIS
PARENTS.
>> Greg: THE CHILDREN!
THEY PUT CHILDREN OUT OF THE
COLD WHICH CAN HAPPEN WHEN YOU
I AM SURE THE GUY PULLED OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL WAS HEARTBROKEN.
CLEARLY IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
TERROR ATTACK IT ALL BUT ABOUT
THE CHILDREN.
THEY ARE RIGHT.
WE SHOULD BE QUESTIONING THE
FAMILY.
WE SHOULD BE PUTTING THEM UP IN
A FIVE-STAR HOTEL WITH NOTHING
MAYBE TICKETS TO A SHOW.
TRY BOOK OF MORMON.
YOU WOULD GET A KICK OUT OF
THAT.
>> THESE ARE NOT THE SORTS OF
ACTIONS WE EXPECT FROM OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
>> Greg: WELL, TERRORISM IS
NOT THE SORT OF THING WE EXPECT
FROM DECENT, LAW-ABIDING HUMANS.
BUT YEAH, IT'S OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM WE'VE GOT TO WORRY ABOUT.
I OFFER THIS HUMBLE SUGGESTION:
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM IS PROTECTING
YOU FROM YOUR OWN FAMILY MEMBER.
YOU SHOULD NOT ONLY THANK THESE
OFFICERS BUT YOU SHOULD
COOPERATE.
IF THIS WERE ANY OTHER COUNTRY,
INCLUDING THE ONE YOU LEFT,
FAMILY MEMBERS OF A TERRORIST
WOULD BE COLLECTED AND PROBABLY
NEVER HEARD FROM AGAIN.
BUT I GUESS THAT IS WHY YOU'RE
HERE.
>> Dana: FROM THEM?
REFLECTIVE.
YOU SEE, ESPECIALLY IN THE U.K.,
NO, ACTUALLY THE POLICE ARE
WORRIED ABOUT CHILDREN TOO WHICH
IS EXACTLY WHY THEY ARE DOING
THAT.
THEY ARE IN A RACE AGAINST TIME.
WHAT IF THERE WAS SOMETHING
COORDINATED.
WHAT IF SOMEBODY KNEW THERE WERE
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT DESERVES OUR FULL
SUPPORT.
>> Greg: THEY ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SAFETY OF THE FAMILY.
THEY DON'T WANT THAT KID TO BE
BEATEN UP OR WHATEVER.
THEIR PRIORITIES TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY IS TAKEN TO A SAFE
PLACE SO THEY CAN BE QUESTIONED.
>> Kimberly: THERE ISN'T
ANYTHING WRONG WITH THAT BUT
THIS IS THE TACTIC THEY DO.
THIS IS REALLY THE BOOK, THEY GO
BY THE BOOK.
ATTACK LAW ENFORCEMENT, ATTACKED
THE AMERICAN JUSTICE SYSTEM.
FIND FAULT, DISTRACT AND DEFLECT
AND FLIP THE SCRIPT TO SAY THIS
IS ABOUT AN INJUSTICE BEING
COMMITTED AGAINST THE TERRORISTS
COMMITTED AGAINST THE TERRORIST
TERRORISTS.
CREDIBILITY AND THEY GO AHEAD
AND THEY ARE SYMPATHIZES FOR
TERRORISTS AND JIHAD AND THEY
ARE ENABLERS AND I HAVE NO TIME
APOLOGIZE?
>> Juan: WHEN THIS FIRST
STARTED, I THOUGHT, WHAT DID
BEAT SOMEBODY UP?
IN MY MIND, WE LIVE IN A COUNTRY
WHERE YOU HAVE TO TAKE YOUR HAT
OFF.
I THINK THE SITUATION WHEN THE
GUY FROM NEW JERSEY, HE WAS -- I
FORGET EXACTLY.
THEY TOOK HIM TO THE HOSPITAL.
>> Greg: THE CHELSEA ATTACK.
NOT SURE.
>> Juan: MY POINT IS, THAT GUY
GETS FIRST-RATE, WORLD-CLASS
MEDICAL TREATMENT.
SAME THING WITH THIS GUY.
THIS GUYS IN THE HOSPITAL.
DAY.
NOT IN THE USA, THANK GOD.
WHEN THEY SAID THIS, I THOUGHT,
WERE THEY ROUGHHOUSING OR?
THEY TOOK THE CHILD OUTSIDE.
40 DEGREES YESTERDAY.
COME ON.
>> Greg: I KNOW.
TERRORIST HAD POST COMMENTS
ABOUT TRUMP ON FACEBOOK?
THANK YOU, YOU FAILED TO PROTECT
AMERICA.
>> Jesse: GOOD ONE, BUDDY.
HE SET OFF THE BOMBS BECAUSE HE
WAS OFFENDED BY A BUNCH OF
CHRISTMAS PLACARDS NEAR THE
TRAIN STATION.
THE GUY IS SO UNGRATEFUL.
A LOT OF THESE BOMBERS, THEY
COME HERE ON A LOTTERY SYSTEM,
SOME IMMIGRATION LOOPHOLE.
THEY GET HERE.
THEY ARE EITHER RECEIVING
WELFARE, FOOD STAMPS SOMETIMES.
FREEDOM OF SPEECH, FREEDOM OF
WORSHIP, FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION
YET THEY HATE THIS COUNTRY SO
MUCH THEY WANT TO ATTACK IT.
AND CAIR IS THE WORST P.R.
AMERICAN MUSLIMS COULD HAVE.
IF I HAD A FAMILY MEMBER THAT
CAME TO ANOTHER COUNTRY, TRIED
TO SET OFF A BOMB AND GOT BUSTED
RED-HANDED, I WOULD APOLOGIZE,
HIDE, AND COOPERATE.
INSTEAD, THEY SENT CAIR OUT TO
READ A STATEMENT TO UNDERMINE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND TRY TO PLAY
THE VICTIM CARD?
IF THEY HAD SET OFF A BOMB IN
>> Greg: I WAS WATCHING
RICK LEVENTHAL.
I DIDN'T KNOW THE GUY USED
CHRISTMAS LIGHTS IN THE MAKING
OF THE BOMB.
>> Jesse: WAR ON CHRISTMAS.
SORRY, I HAD TO.